estas imágenes de miles de migrantes
haitianos agolpados en la frontera con
eeuu llevan días dando la vuelta al
mundo es una parada más de un periplo de
meses en los que han recorrido todo el
continente americano en busca de un
futuro mejor la mayoría de ellos vivían
en chile y brasil desde que se les
acogiera tras el devastador terremoto de
2010 pero la crisis del coronavirus
motivó su marcha hacia el norte para
ello recorrieron toda sudamérica
atravesando el peligroso tapón del
darién en colombia y toda centroamérica
y méxico hasta llegar a la frontera con
eeuu en colombia
miles de ellos se agolparon en la
localidad caribeña de necoclí en julio
aquí permanecieron hasta atravesar la
frontera con panamá un viaje muy
arriesgado debido a la presencia de
grupos armados y a la frondosidad de la
selva factores que costaron la vida de
muchos de ellos los que llegaron a
méxico no se encontraron algo mejor
xenofobia y hambre este país denunció
que su situación se debe a un engaño ya
que nunca podrán ingresar a eeuu y salir
de haití y chile
tener condición de refugio buscar
trabajo ahí hay niños que ya son nacidos
en chile con brasil
que ahora sus dirigentes les digan
vámonos a eeuu rápido porque nos van a
darle la residencia o la nacionalidad
norteamericana posiblemente pues es un
engaño monumental eso no es cierto pero
al final de su viaje no está cerca ante
el miedo a las deportaciones muchos han
decidido continuar el camino a la
inversa por méxico